hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I oh
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical texts I hope you
find it useful as well so Aristotle says
that compulsion being held by by
necessity or force can make any action
in volunteer so it's something that
we're not responsible for ya what might
be some examples of this sort of thick
imagine that I've used this example a
couple other times mention I put a chip
in your head that made you do what it is
that I want you so you're totally
undermine full and I've got some sort of
controller you know imagine something
like double joystick you know the bunch
of buttons and I'm making it go around
so I say well I think I hadn't robbed a
bank so I'm going to make it go into the
bank and pull out of God and type in
they know put all the money the bag you
know are you are you responsible for
that those actions we would say no right
an aerosol would say no because you're
doing the action but you're not choosing
the action somebody else is forcing you
to another example would be imagine that
you're under the influence of some sort
of drug or alcohol of your counter and
all loosey-goosey and I pick up here in
your hand and I whack somebody else
processor I made your hand dude you
didn't choose right you know somebody
else comes along saying yeah that's your
handprint on my face and you can say
yeah I wasn't in charge I wasn't in
control of my own faculties so-and-so
made me do that evil Pakistan we could
imagine all sorts of circumstances like
that think of for example they
multiplied now that we have facebook and
other things people get drunk and what
other people do to them what sort of
things that then they take photos up and
put on facebook draw on them yeah pose
them with things right put them in
situations where you know very
incongruous looking things then snap a
photo if you offloaded he said well
would it would a jackass this person is
you know obviously they put themselves
in this this strange compromising
situation and then they can come along
and they say well you know I didn't
choose to do that they made right now
these are these are easy cases aren't
they these are cases where clearly
you're not in control of what it is what
you're doing he talks about cases where
your tea read somewhere by whether you
want to get somewhere on time we might
say but a rainstorm comes down and you
can't drive safely if we're going to
rain storm like that first people pull
over the motorcycles may under bridges
and that's pretty student ever been
turned on their their hazards and they
get off the road and so you'd miss your
appointment you didn't miss it because
you're challenged to miss Europe
you had to stop something you know in
necessity care elsewhere if you get into
a boat and now we haven't we have a lot
more control because the technology that
we have in Arizona side if you got into
a boat you are pretty much going with a
wind and the waves we're going to take
you you had a rudder and you have a
warrior's of a sale and you might get
somewhere close to where you want to be
but sometimes you might end up somewhere
totally different again not your fault
that that's compulsion that some other
some other force or a necessity that
makes them go the way that they go it
gets more interesting when we're
thinking about other people's bills and
the choices they for signs that negative
a situation where we would stay well
they made me do it I didn't have a
choice I you know I'm sorry but things
have to go this way because I I'm you
know listening to my superiors or
somebody's put me into a difficult
situation and then oftentimes people
plead compulsion and I say I can't
possibly not do that right so that
that's one set of issues another thing
that that come up might be our desires
don't we sometimes feel like we're
straight through our desires we don't
have control over them they they control
us instead when we feel that way they
should some designers like you know
think about what you're really really
tired you know you haven't slept very
well for a couple days we've been busy
doing things I mean pretty soon it's
going to be final exam week and you guys
you can all be totally stressed out and
tired papers and
five things and study for exam but
you're all going to look pretty worn
down you'll be really happy when it's
over you fall asleep you have the
intention of staying away but you fall
asleep because you're unable to resist
your body's own urges you know you felt
that light in your eyes are staring
applause and you're like stop wake up
you're like slap yourself you guys know
what I'm talking about right that get
dangerous when you're going to drive I
can I can drive for about 13 hours
straight and then I start to get sleepy
I'm at that 14 15 16 hour days to make
long-distance drives gets really nicely
you know if I'm smart when I do is it
pull take a nap usually my favorite give
it an accident sorry desires good good
causes to feel like we were being
himself what else it's an event emotions
when you're griff of a very strong
emotion doesn't us sometimes feel like
you don't have a choice the emotions
take those choices of late for me so
let's see what Aristotle says about
these these sort of situations he says
there's some doubt about he actions done
through another emotional fear fear of a
worse alternative or for some noble
object as for example if a tyranny
having a man's parents and children and
his power commands him to do something
something low something base something
ignoble when if he complies their lives
will be spared but if you refuses
they'll be put to death that's a tough
situation right a lot of people would
say you don't have a choice in that kind
of situation Aristotle would say well
you're forced in a certain way but you
also still do have some sort of choice
you are choosing
between different goods if you think
that saving here your family is the most
important thing that's the greatest
value for you you are choosing that
value right and if you think that not
doing something base is is more
important or something that might be
compromising then you're choosing that
that's a reflective of the kind of
person that you are he says it's open to
question whether such actions are
voluntary or involved that's the
question that we want to decide he says
in a somewhat similar case imagine
you're in a storm you're on chef and you
you've got a lot of cargo on that ship
and your life savings are invest in that
cargo that's going to either make your
fortune or you're going to lose
everything and have to start from
scratch storm comes with if you don't
throw that cargo overboard the ship is
going to capsize what do you do do you
through it if you throw it overboard
you'll survive right people will in most
cases that you know jettison the cargo
the question isn't so much what you can
do the question is is that voluntary or
are you being compelled so he says in
cases like this we want to call them
mixed or composite we want to say that
compulsion is entering into that but
that kind of compulsion doesn't make us
necessarily choose the good of the man
we actually do contribute something to
it so he says they're much more like the
voluntary class at the time that they're
done they're chosen who are will isn't
that why we hold people accountable when
they do make those for the decisions we
say yeah I understand that you were
forced but you still didn't you have to
kill that person over there to you know
keep yourself from being exposed if
you're a public figure you know we went
through and said well I was being
blackmailed so therefore i get caps on
that one that said well you should
does something different he says the end
remote of an act berries of the occasion
so the terms voluntary and involuntary
should use with reference to the time of
the action so if we want to think about
compulsion we have to think about those
receivers and he does give you some some
you know ways out he says in some cases
submission the not praise is condoned
what a man does something wrong through
fear of penalties that impose too great
a strain of human nature and that Noah
could endure and by knowing he doesn't
mean nobody ever any time throughout
history because guaranteed if you look
you know you'll find anything that you
could possibly pick there's somebody who
put up with it and actually chose it
because you know they're done billions
of human beings on this planet what it
means is there are certain thresholds
beyond which we would say okay at that
point you're no longer able to keep
yourself keep yourself bad so where do
these thresholds lie he doesn't actually
tell you that it would be nice we did
with that you know exactly how far you
go that's something that we have to try
to figure out where I can shred of
attendance class itself but you know
what could you use do you think as as
reliable guides room if you look at
people that you in wire see how much
they're able to endure and then if it
goes beyond that then you can say yes I
was I was compelled he says there seem
to be some acts which a person cannot be
compelled to do and rather than do them
you ought to submit to the most terrible
death he is an example of a mattress
side which means killing a mother for
the Greeks killing a family member was
considered to be much worse than killing
somebody else and killing a parent was
considered to be much more symptomatic
and brother or sister and killing your
mother is considered to be in some ways
worse than killing her father so Gareth
level says you know there's this guy in
plague which compelled by certain
threats to murderers mother and he says
really he can't he can't say that he's
getting off of that because he's being
threatened that's really his choice and
he says but it is difficult to decide
how far we ought to go and choosing to
do it given act rather than suffer a
given penalty penalty rather than
committee given the action so this is
not something that we have hard and fast
rules for this is something that we have
to sort of know think about and figure
out he also brings up another difficulty
which ties in with the problem of what
we call self-control and laughs at self
control he says once we've actually made
our decision imagine you're in a
difficult choice and you've been you
know you didn't choose the situation
that you're in and both alternatives
seem kind of bad to you and you're like
choosing the lesser of the two evils
it's hard to actually stick with that
choice isn't it because you don't like
either one of the alternatives and he
says when made in these then most of
these dilemmas the penalty thread was
painful and the deed forced if I was
dishonorable and so that makes it quite
difficult he'd saw control for that what
about some other cases that we could
think of if somebody worried that a
hardcore drug user and they tell you
that they
well you know sending you a crime in
order to be able to procure drugs you're
going to steal something so they can
fence it so they can get some unease
that can go get effects would you say
first of all would you say put aerosol
side would you say that that person is
compelling that's not their choice no
they always have a choice Dragic drug
addiction can get pretty serious I think
it can deprive a person not only enough
vital elements of their personality but
you might even say their freedom of will
what would aerosol say how would you see
that I think you know he would be
willing to say that in those cases that
that's one of those instances where it's
going beyond what a person could do you
listen to the accounts of what it's like
to to try to kick heroin or came back
and it's very tough and people generally
fail in unless they've got some sort of
help even even though quitting quitting
smoking or quitting drinking alcohol
pretty tough become addicted to it I
don't quit smoking sometimes means that
you know and stay quit most of times
that I quit right I fail a lot of times
I was through failure but if I would
really really addicted then I wouldn't
have a choice by now you can say well
you made a choice you get addicted but
that's that's more
the past once you're actually in the
grip repulsion what do you guys think
about these desires fears emotions is it
possible to get so angry that you you
can't be held accountable what do you
think
amazing
for example
yeah maybe that's what you tourettes is
a great example because we you know
there's actually the soft firm episode
have you guys see this the south park
episode about Tourette's where cartman
pretends he's got Tourette's because he
gets the square all the time because
people who have tourettes are excused
because of their swearing because it's
gets a neurological condition that your
bodies are doing gassed you they're not
actually choosing the same stuff and
then of course the joke on Cartman is
that he ended ends up with Tourette's
and he finds himself unable to stop
swearing c'mon Stu he find himself in
that case what Cartman would be undoing
he's actually acquiring advice from
Aristotle's perspective that looks like
to rest and you know before people
understood it as a medical condition
people were holding people with
Tourettes accountable for it and saying
you're choosing to swear at me now we
know better we know that look that you
know they can try to resist but they're
gonna fail and whatever they're gonna
head you know hopefully they can keep
themselves saying things that are fairly
wild and not crazy you know terrible
swears and there could be other other
yeah other other medical conditions we
call diagnosable disorder is using the
dsm-4 dsm-5 is not there's a lot of
controversy about it so I would reason
but the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual that people in psychotherapy use
there are certain things that are
diagnosable as severe disorders they
have people in the grip of those we
would say that they are suffering from a
compulsion which they cannot resist
effectively they may be able to resist
it through great force of will and some
circumstances but sooner or later
they're in offense anger could be you
know in capacity control
anger could fit into that and could be
be placed either some situations where
you could take a normal person off the
street who doesn't have anger problems
and just subject them so much abuse that
sooner or later you're going to get the
anger response from them I think so
Aristotle would be smooth be sympathetic
to that sort of thing could there be
some circumstances that are not actually
caused by somebody being mean and
putting that person into that situation
which is all sorts of frustrations that
arise and the person that loses control
imagine like you know who's there your
house did was a job they splashed by the
car going by the puddle total slobs what
else should we add to it the shoes fall
apart they're sick you can just keep
adding one more thing right what a
person who's in that sort of situation
if they lose their temper was that
voluntary or involuntary I think it at a
certain point we would be willing to say
an Aristotle people would say that was
involuntary they think they were pushed
so far that they could it be otherwise
or we'd say this about other promotions
like being sad the depression right some
people are unable to cope get out of bed
sometimes even and people come by and
say come on rise and shine put a happy
face up get out of bed and then they'll
say well you're here you're malingering
you're not actually that sad you're
making
Paris thought would be willing to say
there's some cases where somebody could
you know the reactions are coming from
emotions and there's no I think it's of
the barking hi and if it's if it's a
consequence of our own vitus's of our
own bad choices made over and over again
if every time that I get sad i go and i
lay in bed and I don't talk with anybody
pretty soon I'm going to get depressed
right and maybe my depression in that
case is not the same thing somebody
who's got chemical imbalance it actually
needs antidepressants maybe i'm just
maybe i am in that case malingering and
then i wouldn't responsible or there
wouldn't be impulsive ice you guys are
the difference between those those those
categories there's one other case of
compulsion that aristotle talks about
not in book three but in book seven and
that is what he calls brutality and you
know it gives examples of people who
have been abused or you know things have
gone beyond some examples of way
neurological disorders if you grow up in
a society that is you know really off
kilter as far as its culture imagine for
example growing up in a combat zone
people have all sorts of problems that
come
because of that they're not all
well-adjusted there would be some things
that perhaps we would be willing to
excuse for them and say that they're
unable to keep themselves from reviewing
innovator and crafting Crevan sense of
paranoia if you grew up in a combat zone
maybe that's actually a adaptive
response right we would say that
somebody like that is not as responsible
for their actions you want to try to fix
them we could all right we want try to
make things better for them but we may
not be able to do that and in some cases
you know horrific relief in some cases
of aerosol comorbid disorders that may
not be possible at that point the person
is for Arizona below the level of the
human so they're no longer a human agent
or more just like him more just
following it stinks urges all sorts of
things and he says that this is morally
less bad than vice but it's more
horrific because when you look at
situations like that a normal human
response to that is to do feel a sense
of something's gone terribly wrong those
are pretty rare I think that we can
counter that with compulsion right
sometimes people actually will try to
pretend like that's the case so that
they can excuse their conduct but in our
society things like that
rare whenever wherever manithan rare
larry flynt history so yeah let's
probably enough that about a compulsion